MGM Plus have announced all of their
television shows and shows in
development for the next year but no
sign of Stargate should we be worried
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
[Music]
the brilliant gate world just released a
story telling you guys all about this
big announcement by MGM plus it's all
part of this television critics
association's winter press tour and
we've got a lot of information about
Star Trek yesterday and overnight was
MGM plus his turn Michael Wright
released a statement talking about how
they're increasing the stable of
brilliant content that MGM has including
blockbuster movies and new television
series planned for the future
but no Stargate now in Gate World story
it talks about how well that's not
really a massive shock is it we know
that this is being pitched but we don't
actually think it's at the development
stage yet well that's 100 correct at the
end of the day this was never going to
be announced yesterday because of what
we know that happened just before
Christmas now if you regular snow track
you'll know what I'm talking about but
just to quickly recap penguin and Parker
the company owned by Mark Ferguson hall
ghostby is the front runner to have the
new Stargate franchise but it is not
agreed yet there is no contract there is
no signature on a dotted line
at the moment they're still negotiating
that and they're also going to probably
be looking for other partners to produce
the TV show and movie and I'm going to
go back to that in a second because
that's important and with them in the
future because at the end of the day
penguin and Parker will be the
development arm of this car partnership
they will be the ones developing writing
executive producing the TV show another
company will actually make it I actually
believe they're probably going to end up
doing what they did with the expanse and
they're going to need another company
somebody will step in and actually show
run the project because well Mark Fergus
hasn't done that in the past unless my
focus is planning to step up and
actually take the company a bit further
with this project which God I hope it
does I actually think it's possibly very
likely that another company another
partner will come in and that they will
show Hawk Osby and Mark Fergus will do
all the heavy lifting but another
company will actually own a studio
actually make the show and act like a
manager now as I mentioned before
Christmas there was a series of
negotiations and meetings those meetings
didn't end particularly well now I have
heard some rumors and those are going to
be very much in the rumor category that
actually Mark Fergus when he met Michael
Wright wasn't particularly happy
apparently as well there was a meeting
penciled in with Jennifer sulky from
Amazon but that didn't happen
so Mark Fergus apparently came out of
that meeting rather displeased because
for one the budget that they were being
offered to produce a 10 episode run of a
new Stargate series was roughly half of
what they were hoping for also that
Michael Wright is pushing for this to
appear on MGM Plus instead of Amazon
Prime and that would be worldwide the
Assumption being that it would be an MGM
Plus in the United States and then
worldwide it would appear on a prime now
Mark Fergus his argument apparently is
that you know it won't get the viewers
worldwide people don't watch MGM plus
worldwide
back in the United States it's an
established premium subscription service
but the rest of the world it's just an
add-on to Amazon Prime that no one else
watches
so he is pushing for a different plan
for whatever TV show he then produces
the thing is I believe those meetings
just before Christmas were to finalize
the agreements hopefully get the
contracts at very least in principle
agreed but then Stargate could have been
announced by the January 15th date when
epics becomes MGM Plus in the United
States I think that was always the ideal
plan but negotiations haven't gone as
well as hoped or as quickly as hoped and
they're just not quite been able to make
it now I'm actually being told that
these negotiations is perfectly normal
for a larger franchise remembering that
this project will probably cost at least
60 million dollars hopefully more like
100 million dollars it's not a small
project it's not a small deal now again
talking to the Insiders I speak to
negotiations like this take months it's
normal they just do if ever you've ever
worked in business you'd understand that
any big contract negotiations that the
basically the end result is spending a
hundred million dollars always takes
months and Amazon do work far more like
a business than the traditional studio
so they take even longer so the fact
that these negotiations maybe didn't go
as well as hope Before Christmas really
just means it's part of the negotiation
they might have been aiming for the
middle of January for this announcement
but they just couldn't quite get there
now I'm told that meetings are
continuing from this week into next week
I've actually had a little bit of an
update on that that apparently a lot of
the meetings initially this week aren't
going to be actual face-to-face meetings
there's still some negotiation
discussions going on with lower level
Executives some of the bean counters and
some of the different teams that work on
these proposals and then next week
hopefully there might be a meeting and
that might even include a meeting
between Mark Fergus and Michael Wright
but again at the moment that's all rumor
that's all hearsay let's actually wait
for some confirmation as soon as I get
that though I will be sharing it with
you guys so one of the big reasons it's
not being announced as part of the MGM
Plus plans is because the negotiations
are still ongoing and it's not been
decided definitely that it will appear
on MGM plus Mark Fergus is arguing
against that plan so that's one reason
why it's not on the docket for next
year's plans another reason as I keep
saying to you guys MGM and Amazon would
quite like to do a Stargate movie first
now obviously if they're going to do a
movie first that will go to cinema
that's obviously not going to appear on
the MGM Plus plans for the next 12
months so that's the second reason why
it hasn't appeared as part of these MGM
Plus plans if they do a movie and
negotiations do go as planned and they
can find another partner reasonably
quickly I'm certain that will be the
point where it gets announced I don't
think that's going to be until late
spring at the earliest
then development will start which is the
third reason why it doesn't appear on
this list for new TV shows or shows in
development the simple fact is it isn't
in development we're not at that point
yet the contract has not been signed as
I say so they cannot move forward with
any development and by development I
mean pre-production development not the
development work they've done as part of
the pitch because that's all that has
been done so far the development work is
to get to the point where the executives
have an idea what is planned and that
they can green light it then the real
work really starts the real proper
development I.E writing scripts finalize
in scripts I happen to know that Mark
Fergus is apparently written two maybe
three scripts already that would then
become the first three episodes of this
new series but
the development on those scripts is
really very shallow it's basically been
written shown to Amazon they've gone all
lovely okay now let's go over on to the
next bit
no more than that before a series
actually got made they would be far more
scripts written redrafts etc etc well
before they actually then start making
the project
so those are the main reasons why we
shouldn't actually be worried that MGM
Plus have not announced Stargate for one
it's going to be a movie first chances
are for two it's not in development yet
anyway and for three negotiations are
still going on so let's see what happens
in the next couple of weeks it was
always the plan to have it announced by
now it's not happened that's business
for one final reason why I think it was
never going to be announced as part of
this press junket anyway
was because this is actually a massive
project it will create lots and lots of
interest you don't denounce something
like that on the same day you're
announcing several other things you
announce it on a day where no one's
announcing anything else so that it'll
be the only thing people talk about that
day you want lots and lots of clicks you
want lots of idiots like me making
videos about it you want the attention
to be solely focused on the big project
that's why I never thought it was going
to happen today anyway
so let's see what happens in the coming
weeks we're going to cross our fingers
we're going to keep talking about it on
this channel even though it is getting a
little irritating and we're going to
remember that this process is going to
take a long time but the end result will
be a television show hopefully we're all
going to absolutely adore just as much
as we love the original
but please guys get into the comments
tell me exactly what you think do you
were you expecting this news by now or
do you actually think no everything I've
been telling you on Sidetrack you
completely understand that this is a
process and we'll get there eventually
let's just be a little bit patient I
know patience is difficult though and
it's a show like Stargate that we just
won on our screens immediately but get
in the comments and tell me exactly what
you think if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps Santa and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also if you want to support the channel
a little bit more consider hitting the
join Button as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]